foreign
[Music]
Smith and I'm pleased to be talking to
you today about the current use of G
protein coupled receptors or gpcr
pharmacogenomics in the clinical
practice this is for the lab Roots drug
Discovery and development virtual event
series
I'm a professor at the University of the
Incarnate Word Fike School of Pharmacy
in San Antonio Texas
and there I teach pharmacology and
pharmacogenomics to our Pharmacy
students when I saw that lab Roots was
looking for speakers on the topic of
gpcr pharmacogenomics I thought it would
be fun to talk about where we are in our
ability to apply the current knowledge
of the genetic variants of these
receptors in clinical practice
in this presentation I'll quickly cover
the structure and function of the gpcrs
briefly talk about the medications that
Target these receptors provide an
overview of the genetic variants of
gpcrs and provide an update of the
current ability to use gpcr
pharmacogenomics in practice in an
effort to personalize the use of
Medicine
by the end of this presentation
listeners should be able to describe how
the genetic variants of gpcrs are
thought to affect receptor function
describe in general how known genetic
variants may affect patient responses to
medications that Target gpcrs and you
should be able to list some genetic
variants of gpcrs that are being
evaluated for their clinical impact
so G protein coupled receptors or gpcrs
they are a family of receptors that
signal through the G proteins
they make up the largest family of
receptors in the body
these receptors are transmembrane
receptors they cross back and forth
across that cellular membrane seven
times
this family of receptors includes
receptors for adrenergic amines and
serotonin
acetylcholine lots of peptide hormones
odorants and even light so they are
expressed in the cones and rods of the
retina
when an endogenous ligand or a
medication that targets a gpcr interacts
with the receptor
the receptor stimulates the GTP binding
signal transducer protein or G protein
this activation of the g-protein in turn
modulates production of an intracellular
second messenger
and once that second messenger has been
activated you end up with cellular
responses of various kinds
this is a figure that I adapted from a
chapter in the textbook titled basic and
clinical pharmacology it's the 2021
edition of this textbook and I want to
walk us through this figure a little bit
to understand a bit more the depth of
the actions of gpcrs in this figure the
green circle is a cell and the blue
rectangle is the gpcr
the orange dot is a ligand or a
medication that targets a gpcr
and the yellow blob in the figure there
is a g protein
so if you start on the left hand side of
the cell you'll see that the ligand is
not yet bound to the blue receptor and
in that situation in the absence of a
ligand binding the receptor and the g
protein are present as a complex on the
intercellular membrane of the cell and
at this time the G protein is bound to
GDP
so if you move to the right side
once the ligand binds to the receptor
the G protein subunit the G protein
Alpha subunit will undergo a
conformational change and this will
allow for the release of GDP from that g
protein and then you get The Binding of
GTP into the nucleotide binding site of
that protein hence these these proteins
are called GDP binding proteins
once GTP binds to that g protein then
that g protein is released from the the
gpcr and moves forward with its action
in the cell
so once um once the GTP is bound the G
protein regulates the activity of an
effector protein and this could be an
enzyme or an ion Channel and in this
figure the effector protein is e and
when the GTP bound G protein acts on it
and activates it it's become the E star
in the figure here
so when this effector is activated it
then will change the concentration of an
intracellular second messenger
the signal from the ligand binding to
the gpcr is terminated by the hydrolysis
of the GTP on the G protein
this reaction that inactivates the
g-protein can occur at a relatively slow
late slow rate and this will actually
effectively amplify the transduction of
the signal from the receptor
allowing for the activated G protein to
have a longer lifetime in the cell than
the actual receptor is is being
activated by the ligand so
um
this allows for a long
opportunity for the second Messenger to
be effective
once the GTP is hydrolyzed and G protein
is then Bound Again by GDP the receptor
and g-protein complex are back to their
basal unstimulated state
there are many gpcrs in the body as well
as several different G proteins
the endogenous ligand or a drug that may
bind and stimulate a g protein coupled
receptor can couple to several different
subsets of G proteins this allows for
different g-protein dependent responses
in different types of cells therefore
when gpcrs are activated by a ligand or
a medication you'll see lots of
different kinds of cellular responses
going on throughout the body
so there are many druggable targets for
treatment of common diseases that
involve G protein coupled receptors
as stated in a really great paper by
Hauser that was published in cell in
medications that Target gpcrs make up
about 34 of the drugs that are on the
market today
Hauser found that FDA approved drugs
Target at least 108 G protein coupled
receptors and at the time of the
publication of their paper there were
there were an additional 66 G protein
couple receptors that were being
targeted by drugs and development
the diseases that are treated by gpcr
targeted medications include metabolic
diseases like obesity
reproductive system diseases like
polycystic ovary disease
pain
nervous system diseases like alcoholism
depression schizophrenia Parkinson's dis
Parkinson's disease there's also
pulmonary diseases like asthma and
cardiovascular diseases like
hypertension and heart failure that are
all treated by gpcr targeting
medications
so many gpcrs have genetic variants
the general kinds of genetic variants
that have been found in gpcrs include
Miss sense variations loss of function
variations and copy number variations
a missense variant is a change in the
gene in which a single base pair has
been substituted for another
and this can alter the genetic code in a
way that produces an amino acid that is
different from the usual amino acid
some Miss sense variations will change
the function of a protein
a loss of function variant is a change
in the genetic code such that the
protein being produced is no longer able
to retain its normal physiological
function
um
an example of this would be the
insertion of a stop codon into the DNA
sequence resulting in a truncated
protein that is too short to function
you can also get the insertion of
nucleotides that create a create a frame
shift in the DNA
or you can also get DNA sequence changes
that interrupt splice sites then all
three of these types of genetic variants
can cause loss of function for a protein
the Third Kind of genetic variant that
has been identified in gpcrs include
copy number variants and these are
changes in our genome where you get a
whole Gene is deleted or whole Gene is
inserted you get an extra gene or two
either of these kinds where you have a
gene insertion or a gene deletion will
obviously result in a change in the
expression of the gene so you get more
or less protein than normal
many of these gpcr variant types
um can affect a gpcr function and also
we are finding that many of these
variants that we see in gpcrs may affect
drug response
so in general
the kinds of variants that have been
identified in gpcrs that have been
characterized they've also had their
functional significance evaluated
so across the gpcrs there are drug
binding Pockets ligand binding Pockets
there are G protein or beta arrestin
binding interfaces that have been
affected by these variants
we have found
um uh variants that affect the
allosteric sodium binding pockets
you see changes to the activation micro
switches in these gpcrs and you also see
genetic variants that affect the
post-translational modification of the
protein
so again there are many gpcrs there are
also many variants of these genes and
we're seeing that a lot of these
variants do indeed affect receptor
function
so we also as I mentioned in the earlier
slide know that many of the gpcr genetic
variants
affect drug response when considering
the large number of gpcrs and the fact
that they are targets of many
medications it can be said that in
general these genetic variations are
expected to either decrease drug
efficacy or increase drug efficacy or
change the risk for drug side effects
developing in patients so depending on
the medication being considered
um and the the receptor that that
medication targets you will get these
differences in drug responses in the
presence of these genetic variations
so Hauser and colleagues again pulling
from that paper they published in cell
in 2018 they presented some some nice
data looking at the prevalence and
impact of the genetic variants of gpcrs
so
um
the work that they did they uh
it was very in-depth and I don't have
time it's beyond the scope of this
presentation to present all that they
found in trying to elucidate the
prevalence and impact of the gpcr
genetic variants but I wanted to point
out just a few of the of the information
that they provided in their paper so
um Hauser and colleagues analyzed data
from the 1000 genomes project and this
this project is an international
research Consortium it's organized so
that sequencing of a thousand volunteer
genomes is is publicly accessible and
these volunteers came from a variety of
places around the world and the purpose
of that Consortium was to provide data
to help increase our understanding of
how human genomes contributes to health
and disease so Hauser in their paper
queried the uh sequences from the
Thousand genomes project and they found
that many missense variations in gpcrs
are drug targets
um so what they found they found about
60 missense variant 60 missense variants
in gpcr drug targets and on the flip
side of that they found that about 40
gpcr drug targets Had A missense
variation
they also found that there are nine
politically known missense variations
that affect drug efficacy or toxicity in
gpcr drug targets per individual and
then they also found that there are six
gpcr drug targets with clinical missense
variants per individual as well so this
data that Hauser and colleagues
published is is clearly indicating that
the gpcr genetic variants have an impact
on
um or its predicted impact on drug
response
so this leads me to the next part of my
presentation here
um
I would like to look and see or present
to you where we are now in using this
large amount of information about gpcr
genetic variants and how these efferent
variants might be affecting patient
responses to medications
um keep in mind that the data regarding
the functional significance of gpcr
genetic variants it can be fairly hard
to tease out in clinical studies we we
have good data coming from the bench but
when you start
evaluating the impact of these genetic
variants in patients it can be difficult
the reason for this is because their
patients are just complex and the
strength of an association between a
generic variant and its functional
effect on a patient's drug phenotype can
be hidden in that complexity
given that as more pharmacogenomic
studies are conducted we are now
starting to identify some medications
that clinicians should be aware of that
are likely being impacted by variants of
the gpcrs
in particular we have information about
the functional significance of gpcrs
that Target medications that deal with
some heart disease and some CNS
conditions so I'll be talking about
those those next
so the first
uh gpcr genetic variants that I want to
talk about in relation to medications is
the oprm1 gene this Gene codes for the
MU opioid receptor
and of course opioid receptors are
widely distributed throughout the
central nervous system and in our
peripheral tissues
um the MU opioid receptor is one of the
three receptors that are logically
responsible for uh opioid mechanisms of
analgesia and also mediate the adverse
effects from our opioid medications
the oprm1 gene is highly polymorphic in
other words it has lots of genetic
variants
about 200 known variant alleles have
been identified
the widely studied variant in the oprm1
gene is the one called RS 17
99971 also called the a to G change at
nucleotide 118 or also referred to as a
change from
asparagine to aspartic acid at codon 40.
this variant has been studied for its
role in opioid response in alcohol and
opioid use disorders this particular
variant results in the elimination of
The receptors and glycosylation site and
it's associated with reduced expression
now the reduction in expression of this
gene or of this of this receptor in the
presence of this variant has been found
in vitro
the data is a little bit out there on
whether
expression levels are are significantly
found in in Vivo models
but
um be that having said that we do find
that the glial of this variant is
associated with increased efficacy when
Naltrexone is being treated or is being
used to treat alcohol use disorders so
Naltrexone is an oprm1 antagonist and it
um
the reduction in the the number of
receptors in the presence of the rs17
99971 oprm1 variant is thought to uh
reduce The Binding targets and which may
explain the improved response to
Naltrexone in some patients being
treated for opioid I mean opioid and
alcohol use disorder
so at this point in time even though we
have some clinical data that supports
the in vitro information about the
genetic variant of this Gene we don't
yet have
recommendations for changing the use of
Naltrexone in the presence of this
particular genetic variant
but there is a a document that has been
published it's called the clinical
pharmacogenetics implementation
Consortium guideline or the cpicg
document
this this particular document is
published talking about opioid therapy
in the presence of 2d6 and oprm1 and
comt genotypes so this particular
guidance Document Speaks a lot to the
need to address opioid dosing in the
presence of different cytochrome p452 D6
variants but does not yet talk about how
we change dosing in the presence of this
particular oprm1 variant that I've been
discussing but I want to give you guys a
heads up that is more clinical data is
gathered and the information is refined
we might find in time that this
evidence-based guidance document
is able to provide clinicians with
information to help them adjust the use
of opioids in the presence of this oprm1
genetic variant
okay a second uh G protein coupled
receptor genetic variant and drug that I
would like to talk about is the gene
coding for the serotonin 2A receptor
this receptor is coded by the htr2a Gene
and the receptor is responsible for
postsynaptic serotonin signaling in the
CNS
there have been three genetic variants
in the htr2a Gene
and these are being looked at to see if
they have an impact on the efficacy and
the adverse reaction profile for the
ssris which are selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor medications used for
depression
two of the variants that have been
identified in the htra
um Gene are the ones listed on this
slide there is a RS 6311 and an rs-6313
variant these are in strong linkage
strong leakage disequilibrium this means
these two variants often occur together
and it's felt that the that these two
Snips may be associated with reduced
messenger RNA being expressed off this
Gene and this would therefore reduce
receptor density
however again
um RNA expression studies
um have failed to consistently
demonstrate that there is a real drop in
mRNA levels in the presence of these
snips
however that being said again
um when a particular SSRI is evaluated
um paroxetine there is some data that
suggests that there is an increased risk
of Adverse Events associated
excuse me with the use of paroxetine in
the presence of these two variants
um this data that is indicating that
these Snips are associated with
paroxetine side effects is pretty robust
um but we're still needing more clinical
studies to verify that this indeed is
information that can be clinically
useful
but just to point out to you that again
the these two variants of the hdr2a gene
in association with the use of ssris is
something that clinicians need to be
looking for is a statement that was
again made in another uh cpic G guidance
document and this was a statement that
said there is an increasing evidence
that variations in the genes encoding
for the serotonin transporter and for
the serotonin 2A receptor htr2a are
associated with SSRI response and
adverse effects
is as additional studies are published
we might find that these gene-based
dosing recommendations for these two
genes may be warranted so this quote
from another CPI C guidance document
dealing with the ssris I think is
important to know about and to
remember that as more data is coming we
might be able to adjust our use of ssris
based on the pharmacogenomics of the HTR
2A Gene
and then finally the last
but uh G protein coupled receptor
genetic variant and medication uh
Association that I'd like to like to
talk about is the uh are some genetic
variants in the gene coding for the
beta1 adrenergic receptor so the gene
that codes for this receptor is the ADR
B1 Gene
um beta blockers which especially the
beta1 adrenergic receptors antagonists
they are used extensively to treat
hypertension and they target this gpcr
there are two commonly studied variants
of the ADR B1 Gene the variant that I'm
going to call the Arginine 389 to
glycine variant is one of those and the
second variant is the serine to glycine
codon 49 variant
so the Arginine 389 to glycine change
results in a change in G protein
coupling and resulting adenos cyclase
activity in the cell and the serine to
glycine at codon 49 change is associated
with an increased Agonist promoted
desensitization of The receptors so um
these two genes these variants have
significant functional effect on the
receptor we also see that these two
genetic variants in the adrb1 gene are
associated with the presence of certain
cardiovascular phenotypes in patients
so the way that the genetic variants
these two genetic variants of the adrb1
gene seem to be associated with the use
of beta blockers is that we're finding
that patients that carry the Arginine
389 and or the serine 49 alleles they
may have enhanced responses to beta
adrenergic receptor antagonists so in
other words patients with those
genotypes they may be responding better
to beta blockers especially our beta1
selective blockers like metoprolol
and just to walk you through the history
of where we are with being able to use
this pharmacogenomic information about
this particular receptor is um
I'd like to kind of walk you through
some of the data that has been has been
put forth so far so there were several
small clinical studies that were giving
us good indication that these two
genetic variants were impacting beta
blocker efficacy
um then uh it was decided that larger
studies needed to be done to really
validate this information so one of the
studies that was developed was What's
called the pair study it's the
pharmacogenomic evaluation of
antihypertensive response
so this was a study
where they did a randomized controlled
trial of looking for candidate genes and
genome-wide associations looking to see
if which what genetic variants might be
picked up in the adrb1 gene that's
associated with beta blocker response so
for the para study they enrolled 800
uncomplicated uncomplicated hypertensive
patients and subjects were randomized to
a diuretic which was Hydrochlorothiazide
or to Atenolol one of our beta blockers
and they gathered information on how
well patients were responding to either
of these medications alone or in
combination
and this study was like I said was
designed to help identify
genetic determinants of antihypertensive
response in these patients using these
drugs in the presence of different adrb1
genetic variants
so this was a very fruitful study it
helped to solidify the previous data
that again that Arginine 389 and or the
serine 49 variants of adrb1 were driving
response to beta blockers
and now that we have gotten uh better
data or more you know a larger pool of
data to pull from from with regard to
this adrb1 and this genetic variants we
now are finding some good information
out there for clinicians to use so this
slide here is showing you a screenshot
of a really great website it's called
The Farm gkb website this is a website
that's just full of pharmacogenomics
information for you know all sorts of
all sorts of genes and Drug Pairs and
this particular screenshot that I took
of this website I'm showing you here
that the adrb1 gene is now considered a
VIP it's a very important pharmacogen
in other words the farm gkb folks are
letting us know that we have lots of
good information about the adrb1 genetic
variants and how these variants are
impacting uh drug response in patients
so this website's fun to get into and
knows around in and you can see
annotations of what's out there in the
literature for the variants of the Gene
and you can look at annotations of drug
labeling and you can also find
um
cpic guidance documents on this website
so the next big thing coming for the
adrb1
variants of interest that I've been
speaking about and the use of beta
blockers is one of these cipc guidance
documents that is being proposed so I
think very soon we will have access to a
guideline for beta blockers that talks
about their use in the context of sip2d6
adrb1 also adrb2 and some of the the um
gbks that are present and affecting the
activity of gpcr so in other words we
will soon have an evidence-based
guidance document put out by the cpic
which is the clinical pharmacogenetics
implemented implementation Consortium
and these evidence-based guidance
documents provide information to
clinicians about how we can best use
pharmacogenomics information that we
have so I expect that in this guidance
document we will see it very clearly
stated that the
Arginine 389 and the serine 49 variants
of adrb1 will be impacting how we choose
to use beta blockers and patients so
that's a heads up this would be the
first gpcr that has genetic variance
with evidence-based guidance document
helping us to use and apply
pharmacogenomics in clinical practice so
I think that's very exciting
and finally
um I think that it's good to always
provide listeners with resources that
they can go to
um these two particular resources I've
already mentioned uh the Farm gkb
website again this this website is
fantastic it provides lots of
information about known genetic variants
their functional significance and how
these genetic variants are affecting
um drug response or how how close we're
getting to understanding how these
genetic variants are affecting drug
response
and I mentioned previous on the previous
slide that you can access those cpic
guidance documents on this Farm gkb
website
then the second bullet I have here on
this slide is referring to an FDA table
it's called the table of pharmacogenomic
biomarkers and Drug labeling this is
another great resource that I direct my
students to all the time so this table
provides information about
pharmacogenomics that appears in FDA
approved drug labels so once we get
enough information about how
pharmacogenomics are affecting drugs
this will eventually be put into the
labeling of medication so soon I think
once that cipc guidance document for the
beta blockers is out there for us we
will soon see that information in the
drug labeling for the various beta
blockers that are affected by the the
genetic variance of that adenergic
receptor so
um
uh please uh spend some time looking at
either of these or both of these these
resources I think that they are changing
all the time so it's easy for scientists
and clinicians to keep up with where we
are in the in the um in the land of
pharmacogenomics so
um I thank you for your time and my last
slide here is providing you with the the
articles that I cited in my presentation
so thank you very much